ae
e aí galera chegou na altura vocês
comigo não trabalhar não eu já falei o
vídeo passada cheguei de viagem à
turquia arrumado aqui do eu não consigo
controlar a gráfica foi muita correria e
fui lá para o teatro fazer apresentar o
show beneficiente é que eu só tô em casa
para dormir daqui a pouco eu vou sair
pro jogo beneficiente vai ter na
potycabana é isso não vai ficar assim
até 9 que dar tempo a uma habita no
começo de janeiro é dia 5 foi meu
aniversário em janeiro eu só consigo me
lembrar de uma coisa o bota vala
ainda vou contar uma coisa pra vocês que
eu não sei se é assim com vocês mas
comigo assim quando estava na 4ª série
na 5ª série para janeiro era um mês mais
penso da minha porque eu e você tinha me
traz muitas baixas e levar as pessoas
para chegar nessa casa da amiga que em
janeiro época de comprar os materiais
eu não sei você que estuda ou estudou em
escola particular mais eu que estudaram
em escola pública para o meu futuro e ia
ser decidido aí minha mãe saiba meu pai
de cadu falar você olha a gente vai
comprar o material de você vai ficar em
casa do pai nosso que estais no céu
santificado seja o vosso ano que vem a
nota boa para nós ver você que não sabe
quem é de família humilde e que estudou
em escola pública a dele inteira não que
queiram estudar em escola pública não
seja o mesmo mas quem é de família bem
humilde minka o material escolar ele tem
um valor muito grande na vida da criança
minha mãe chegar naquele material olhar
silva está chegando a gente já sabe que
a nossa cola para cada um cada pacote um
lápis borracha caneta e um cabelo
esse caderno desse dinheiro você naquele
ano um tiro porque eu ia ficar assim
tentando imaginar essas vias para você
que na verdade eu sei que não é da
favela disse que não sabe como quer a
ajuda das pessoas para você não sabe
qualquer hierarquia da escola nando na
minha escola assim que tinha um caderno
de capa dura é um caderno de capa mole
mas nem por isso que sei que você seria
user
z o resto do agora se você esse caderno
capa dura meu amigo de tomar um lanche
do derrubar o candidato da bíblia da
primeira vez que se viu um caderno de
capa dura em casa assistindo a um boom
em chegou descer da moto com meu pai
minha luta reggae que ele monte de
caderno de coisa oculta ajuda celbi
nesse ano 2000 perdendo aquele caderno
com a síndica aquela capa não do bravo
do olhar aquele surfista assim ó porque
cada e pobre gás ele pode até ser capa
do mal ele tem que ter uma mulher sai na
água assim oitentão surfista que ser da
tilibra pois é a minha mãe chegou porque
elas a cobra amigo quando eu sentia
falei [ __ ] que pariu a ostentação vai
começar logo se fosse o dia que cheguei
na escola com os cadernos do catar doha
no catar
tá tá tá tá tá tá tá tá não podiam
passar de ano mas de uma coisa tenho
certeza caderno de capa dura
a tentação de trocar de capa dura passar
na frente da china tira a continuidade
do bom dia pra mim eu falei o o material
escolar ele tem um valor muito grande na
vida de quem é humilde também recebi um
lápis e borracha não me quando eu entrei
naquele material que eu vi aquele um
lápis e uma borracha minha mãe de olhar
pra mim palavras inglesas windows o im o
céu ainda sou você perca sua vida uma
não perca essa borracha os tempos atrás
de mim quando eu era bem educado a mãe
dá uma borracha cair na primeira série
ela durar até a quarta hora tinham fator
surpresa na sacola de compras de volta
às aulas que sua mãe tivesse cintura
cada um dia bom de ver é se sente feliz
com vida tivesse recebido assim o 13º
vai guardar só comparar os materiais até
as coisas brilhantes boas talvez talvez
dentro dessa cola ds uma caneta com três
cores a motoneta de fez comigo aí
conheceu e me seguir mesma escola amiga
de capa dura de 3 cowell tentação de
marta voltas
ao entender primeiro caderno capa dura
não estava certo ao assistir a ação do
banco eu sofri na minha vida 2 288 do
douro se tudo sair daqui sem clicar em
gostei do túnel tentação não dá para
vacilar dessa insatisfação no placar
mandando público não gostei pra ajudar
nós e achou eu quero que você comente
aqui embaixo para melhor coisa ea pior
coisa que aconteceu com você na volta às
aulas é a primeira vez que está aquecido
vídeo meu vídeo com a cor do meu canal é
só clicar aqui embaixo inscrever-se toda
vez que tiverem novo negão você vai
saber e anai
e como vocês puderam perceber que a
imagem está muito muito mais diferente
está um pouco mais aberta dá pra mim mas
tudo assim é um pouco assim como se
fosse um olho de peixe essa câmera gopro
essa câmera gopro grande representar
canon ea loja me ajuda com meus cursos
para melhorar o canal está sem fazer um
vídeo novo pra vocês e ganhar dinheiro
para sustentar seu time
estou fazendo esse vídeo que você ver
como é que é tal o próximo tá na a1 aqui
o link da lógica não é o primeiro link
na descrição do vídeo é bem embaixo e eu
temos ninguém embaixo líquida pelo inter
o meu twitter pra você me seguir é muito
bom você segue no twitter você nunca
está perdendo a atualização e matthew
twitter ou facebook embaixo de um está
grande e é nóis valeu prestar aqui
estamos aqui para tudo o que precisaram
as vezes dos nossos momento que está
passando que agora falou